[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le moment des
galéjade on va rigoler un peu
veuillez-nous chanter la balade la
balade des gens heureux je connais pas
très bien les par veyeznous chanter la
balade mais si la balade des gens
heureux improvisé la mélodie est très
jolie
je peux chanter ce qui VI comm vous
voulez oui comme ça oui comme ils sont
en train de manger oui
oui voici le moment des grillades nous
allons boire un verre ou de et alors
nous allons chanter la
balade la ballade des gens
heureux nous allons chanter la balade la
balade des Gux encore numéro 3 numéro
4 numéro 1 numéro 2 pourquoi pas je vais
vous chanter la balade la balade des
gens
heureux je vais vous chanter la balade
la balade des gens
heureuxinpiration marchez vous donne la
colade giscar vous parle au coin du feu
à deux il chante la balade la balade des
gens heureux à deux il chante la balade
la balade des gens heureux à la saison
des
barricade les agents marchent de par de
pour mieux protéger la balade la balade
des gens
heureux pour mieux protéger la balade la
balade des gens
heureux et comme ça les pauvre diable
n'ont pas besoin de voir les cieux ils
n'ont qu'à chanter la balade la balade
des gens heureux ils nont qu'à chanté la
balade la balade des
gensux pardonnez si je reste en rade car
ce soir je suis malheureux même en vous
chantant la
balade la balade des gens heureux même
en nous chantant la balade la balade des
gens
heureux